[Musique]
moi
jamais je pense à ma mère elle l'adorait
et nous on adorait la taquiner avec ça
en débarrassant ses affaires je suis
tombé sur une lettre dans laquelle elle
m'annonçait que guy jamais était mon
père c'est ma maman qui m'a soufflé
l'idée de faire un portrait sur vous
c'est une fan d'elle vous elle vous
aimez vraiment beaucoup
et papa
[Applaudissements]
vous sentez un peu dépassée des fois où
pas dépasser ouais non je crois pas que
tu deviens artistes je crois que c'est
un état d'âme
moi je sais pas si j'ai du talent mais
je sais que je suis un artiste en tout
cas l'esprit d'états d'âme ceci est une
colère de souviens-tu de notre première
fois vous avez des enfants mais j'ai un
fils que j'ai eu avec anne marie day
qu'un fils qu'on jette un fils c'est
déjà pas mal
pendant je vois ce que tu filmes ne suis
pas stupide du fima vieil homme que tu
trouves vieux donc ils n'aiment rien
t'as même pas avec des couilles c'est ce
qui a mis 1 10 m et 6 février qui fut
dit je n'ai en tout cas j'ai vécu je
suis ravi d'accueillir si jamais j'avais
je n'ai pas changé on change pas on se
prend des habous
[Musique]
c'est bien bien
et l'asm
enchantée dit jamais